okay are we on all right great
Ralph was it appropriate for the
president to tweet in America we don't
worship government we worship God yes
why wouldn't it be
yeah I don't get the question I mean
it's you know I guess no one's for us
worshipping the government are they no
okay good I mean I'm not for worshiping
God but I guess my yeah hardest yeah
yeah well no no once if that's why we
write the question my gosh no overtime
we we get whatever people send in should
reporters be worried that the Trump
administration will go after them for
their sources as they try to contain
leaks
you mean kind of ah you mean kind of
like Obama did you know Bhama dude he
did yeah right that's absolutely right
Obama out here is a fan yourself but she
didn't have the Attorney General up on
the podium essentially saying they're
going to tighten the screws I tell you
what scary is what he was saying in
Virginia West Virginia yesterday but
telling that crowd you know they're
trying to take it away from you you know
this is third-world stuff when you when
you start putting that ID in people's
heads because I what what is going to
happen if it comes to that were they
going to remove where he is impeached or
they remove him from office and he don't
want to go I don't think he's gonna go
voluntarily I think I think we're
getting a little ahead of ourselves
no no no well what learning is a
reporter that a guy I mean they're
talking impeachment well is that the
agenda whoa
we need to have a little more evidence I
got right now well you know when your
son takes a meeting with the Russians
and the headline on the email from him
mm-hmm says you know we have dirt from
the Russian government on your opponent
just taking that meeting to me is
traitorous I don't care what was said at
the meeting or anything came out of the
meeting by the way I just on that point
and mr. Reid I mean I've written a lot
about Russell meets Gaia and that whole
affair this is a woman who by her own
admission to The Wall Street Journal has
a personal relationship with Yuri Chaika
who's the prosecutor general of Russia
if Jeff Sessions sent one of his
lawyerly minions to a foreign country to
feed dirt on an opposition candidate you
bet that that country would raise hell
over the fact she also was a defense
attorney for a Russian money laundering
entity accused by the New York Southern
District of having received millions of
dollars from a notorious tax fraud
perpetrated a decade ago she's been a
lobbyist against US sanctioned a google
search on this woman would have told the
Trump camp stay the hell away the fact
that she got that meeting couldn't agree
more important wait Donald Trump jr. has
said that if he had to do it over again
he would have he would have been but his
father said that anybody thinking that
way is she wasn't sent by the Russian
government she was sent by a bizarre pop
music promoter under a false guy that
she had no nation know that was his
Santa Donald I can't elevated on my own
little morning I was the one who sent
out in a loud and you ought to meet with
the housing on Republican bubble I don't
have people I don't think people believe
yes hello
if SIL Bob Muller says right wasn't okay
tell us somebody has it all I'm saying
is I'm not defending this woman or
saying that the meeting should have
happened all I'm saying is until
somebody has tangible real evidence that
she coordinated with Russian government
officials and setting up the meeting
that information harmful to Hillary
Clinton was presented then it's a
nothing meeting and by the way there
there's only one proven evidence of
collusion by any foreign government with
a campaign or a party during the last
election and it was when an operative
for the Democratic National Committee
this has been reported by Politico went
to the Ukrainian embassy
I met with ukrainian officials got
information damaging to Paul Manta Ford
leaked it to the media leaked it to
other people
and he was forced to resign as campaign
manager because of it that was a foreign
government and a Democratic National
Committee operative but it did that the
information the Ukrainian embassy had
came from Ukrainian reporter who
disclosed it an anti-corruption
although the DNC operative is Ukrainian
American who is in charge was outraged
the Democratic National Committee direct
but what I'm saying is it came from
civil society not the Ukrainian
government notion information happened
to the nodos actually no that has not
been demonstrated to be true the ledger
Amanah for in the black liner the ledger
that was presented has not been
demonstrated to be authentic and even if
it was authentic this was the influence
of a foreign government in a campaign
and again it gets back to the selective
outrage you know that nobody's upset
about that going on but everybody's
upset about rush but it wasn't it wasn't
a foreign government and yet in the camp
again you can find any example of
anything in some small degree somewhere
else can I read just what the the email
said that Don junior got very high level
and sensitive information that is part
of Russia and it's government support of
mr. Trump Russia and it's government
support of mr. Trump yeah this is from
the pop music promoter right okay well
that the only one of those people you
honestly but he was a liaison you
honestly believe that a conspiracy to
have the Russian government collude with
the Trump campaign that the intermediary
would be a pop music promoter well he
was really his father those things are
done it's not that worse than Natasha
it's not John Rocker right yeah who can
find semi-anonymous laudably deniable
people and they were founded as
emissaries by the way at that meeting
was a man called Rinat Akhmetov mission
was in the KGB during the Soviet period
you can read about this in the New York
Times so a former quote-unquote Russian
spy attended the meeting with miss
vessel needs Gaia which Don Johnny hey
Garrity what and the poll information
did he provide anybody we don't know
okay frankly I don't trust anybody who's
at that meeting because they all say
different things
economy it immediately went to a
discussion of Russian adoption and the
Magnitsky Act yes they all say that
Nestle nice gaya was campaigning a
magnet Rania's checks and emails from
people who were in the meeting saying
this is a waste of my time get me out of
here and yet God mavin you're changed
his explanation for taking the meeting
and the contents that were discussed
there in multiple tea also he also
released the emails to the American
public and is cooperating hourly with
all the viewer now I'm back at literally
Clinton deleted $33,000 here we go claim
that every email would always delete it
it was just one much to just one
question Comey has testified that she
deleted work and State Department
related even if there was an email from
someone who we had said about bang that
said hey there's an Iranian government
lawyer or a North Korean government
lawyer who wants to come and eat with us
to give a [ __ ] on Donald Trump you and
every other Republican in this country
would be calling her a traitor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and his father is hiding that you know
we would have known we would have said
the same thing that we said about John
Podesta John Podesta when he got when he
got spam his password in and allowing
somebody to get his emails we would have
self that was not a smart thing to do it
was not a smart thing to have a meeting
that doesn't make it treasonous okay and
it doesn't I'm going to tell you have no
evidence that it is either
we're not get all the way or fit it is
even make it off the subject on
something on beyond that I have no
opinion on the matter um before I get
back to the cards because we're talking
about about the Antichrist what I was
wondering and maybe maybe you can answer
this for me what is the difference
between the Antichrist and the double
they're not the same person right no
they're not there are two different
fictional characters well I'm not okay I
mean what religious figures whatever but
so there's the devil and this the
Antichrist but there must be some they
competitive does one work was one below
that is the devil does the devil work
for the Antichrist is the integration of
a like why what is their relation to I
want to know we were I didn't know we
were know that I didn't know we were one
a Bible study tonight I just want to in
it yes please tell me the relationship
between the devil and the Antichrist
okay the the devil is the the enemy of
God and of heaven and of God's people he
seeks to kill them destroy them deceive
them okay the Antichrist comes along at
a stage in history and we don't know
when it's in the book of Revelation but
he acts as a deceiver and an instrument
of the devil to deceive people and get
them to he the in equation works for the
devil ultimate level is undone got it
which one on MIDI charge contract
employee
Kristen could Trump's approval numbers
ever go below 35 they could in part of
why I say that is I am no longer in the
business of ruling out any possible
outcome when it comes to Donald Trump on
the high or low end he still has a lot
of support within the Republican Party a
lot of support you know that when he
makes the case that people are out to
get him and that's why things have not
necessarily all panned out quite as well
as you'd have said there there weren't
awful lot of voters that say yeah I
don't trust the media I don't trust the
government this sounds good to me and
and I think that within his own party as
long as he's able to hang on to 60 to 70
percent and maybe keep one every five
independence you you hover around that
35 you know what he's doing more than
that right now
I mean he's roughly 80% among
Republicans and I can just tell you bill
that regardless of what the polls say I
live right next to Georgia 6 which was
the most expensive congressional race in
history 60 million dollars in a
congressional race this is a district
that is not Trump country Donald Trump
only carried it by 1.5 percent of the
Genesis offer look exactly and this is a
+10 Republican district and so Trump is
not necessarily the most popular guy in
the district but he came in he
campaigned for karen handel did not
disassociate herself from from him he
did robo calls for he did a fundraiser
for and and karen handel won by four
points I think the the 35% they're
asking about here's an interesting stat
32% of Trump voters think this Don
junior meeting didn't take place even
though the source of it is Don junior
that there's some loyalty there but here
but here's something Trump is doing he
had a rally in West Virginia the other
night and what he did from the stage was
essentially say they're coming after me
they're trying to disempower you and
take away your vote yes what he was
doing though I think was clever he was
trying to conscripted into this Russia
scandal in
about something broader than his
possible personal corruption or his
families or his staff he is thinking
ahead a couple steps so that if he is
indicted or someone close to him is
indicted he is going to have the
strength and the following to back him
up in a way that Richard Nixon didn't
Nixon party abandoned him Trump is
strengthening that connection with his
followers so that he doesn't fall below
70% well I think and personally I think
that he that the Trump team has gone to
school on the way Clinton handled his
own difficulties they look at how they
have actually made it artisan they went
after the special prosecutor and they
said this is out to stop my agenda and
we'll see how this is even but that's an
articular has studied and talked to
Lenny Davis who was Hillary's yet bold
during bill during the Whitewater
investigated literally taking the same
play but the other thing to bear in mind
is that Monica Lewinsky didn't set foot
in the White House until two years after
the special prosecutor had been
appointed but these are the sorts of
things that can spiral and develop and
so it's possible that at this point in
time there was no collusion and nothing
happened but if somebody changes their
story under oath that's how you get well
and this is that this is why special
counsels
and independent prosecutors are such a
bad idea because it's know if there's a
reason why the law was allowed to lapse
and it wasn't renewed because because
when Ken Starr started out investigating
a a real estate deal in the Ozarks right
and he ended up chasing a blue dress
right all right Patrick Fitzgerald was
appointed to find out who leaked Valerie
Plame's name on day one he knew who all
three sources were and he had determined
it was not a crime and Scooter Libby
still got indicted and I am convicted
and I had friends who had to go before
the grand jury two three four times and
ran up hundreds of thousands of dollars
in bills and what a lot of people don't
think about in a moment like this is it
isn't just Donald Trump and it isn't
just his family members they're they're
well-off financially it's everybody else
gets caught into this dragnet did
nothing wrong and our borderline
bankrupted because of a special
prosecutor that goes among my hope that
doesn't happen would Bob Mueller I
understand that he's a stand-up guy and
I hope it doesn't happen but the history
of these individually councils is not
encouraging legal bills are a problem I
agree Ralph compared to the survival of
the Republic oh I think it's right if
and this is what you're worried about
about the inguk no bill I mean we're
talking a nothing is perfect no I'm
talking about people who were I wanted
to investigate one thing can they go
investigate another right but keep in
mind that the special counsel was
appointed because President Trump fired
the FBI director the FBI director said I
took him to contemporary nice notes
because I thought the president's gonna
lie about the contents of our
discussions and also I felt he was
putting undue pressure on me as FBI
director to make this whole Russia thing
go away if they're going to get him on
anything it'll probably be obstruction
of justice rather than do you believe
you're asleep
glad Amir Putin has ordered the murder
of people absolutely do you think Trump
is capable of that no do you know I
don't think so well I can tell you it's
at least as I do I think he loves
dictators loves the way they behave
complements them all the time Sisi and
that nut in the Philippines and air21
and kim jongwan is a smart cookie what
do you think I think you think I was I
was capable of what I would not her I
would not hazard a guess but I would say
that he's capable and likely to fire Bob
Muller if you can at some point
and the big question over the next one
to three years is will he have the
strength to survive the constitutional
crisis involved I don't agree with that
by the when I cry I don't I don't
believe you I don't believe the official
assassination yes do you think he's
capable of ordering that if he could I
think if he if he thought he could get
away with it he would but one thing that
we've learned is the resiliency of
American institutions has checked this
guy tremendously that he's the man
raging in the power why can't I do what
I just want to do and we've seen from
Republicans more skeptical of Trump than
Ralph that in the Senate they've moved
to block him from
removing Muller is easily his hood right
now by putting in some laws by having
there be an appeals process in the event
that he does Manimal around to all the
contrary the barriers as well had
publicly he has no intention of firing
Baltimore as he himself suddenly lawyers
time looking at the relevant fact time
we'll thank you very much everybody
[Applause]